- In the beforetimes, everyone stayed here, in the pocket.
Quarterbacks were slow, respected, and allowed to be wrong every now and then.
- Dang, another pick.
- We've got more picks
- We’ve got plenty.
- RRRAUGHHH... THE AVERAGE QB HAS 2.7 SECONDS
IN THE POCKET RAUGHHHHH
- Rushers! RUN!
- Don’t you get it?
We can't.
- Razor! Razor! Who's the Mike, who's the Mike?
- Hut, audible! Hut, one, two.
- Uh, uh, Omaha!
- Sammy, you know I’m a cornfed passer, but you ever think there’s
a world outside this here pocket?
- If I think about my circumstances, I cry.
- Swamp Cat need to purr.
- Oh no, my ghost vision sixth sense! Warn the guards!
- You know, a real good show would be about us offensive lineman.
- Yes Elgton Jenkins—
- So the problem is—
- [Together:] Nobody notices when we DON’T let people in.
- Yeah.
- Dear Mom and Dad, I’m not enjoying camp anymore.
Pick me up.
- I have a big lead, so I'm probably not going to make it.
Find the disciples of Vick!
- ALL RIGHT! BYE, Y'ALL.
- I'm sweating more than a linebacker at Sunday morning service.
Sweet Bojangles!
- My leg arms are as good as my top arms!
- The whole world is a pocket to me!
- Yo, fam. What up?
- Thank you…running backs?
- Bruh, still?
- I’m more tired than butter on a city slicker’s biscuit!
Sheesh! I’m as tired as a hog workin’ a double shift!
I’m more tired than a coyote at a carnival!
I’m more tired than a gator on a rollercoaster!
I’m more tired than a banjo on a bayou!
I ran faster than one of them Gridiron Heights cartoons!